every Monday Jeffrey Balu Z age 26 combs
the beach as part of a cleanup crew from
the what Tamil Marine Association each
time they pick up about four big sacks
of plastic waste they're paid the
equivalent of four euros a day that
beans iron 16 euros a month that's not
very much but they're all happy to do
this work Jeffrey has been part of the
crew since its inception my main
intention was just to change the
environment itself consist the
environment was difference here there
was a lot of taka taka and this was
dangerous even to the sea creatures so
that's what brought me here but they
bring the trash to a recycling center
run by the organization not far from the
beach shakeela wa helps sort the trash
he lives on the grounds of the recycling
center they separate hard and soft
plastic part of it is given to local
artists and women's associations which
make flip-flops sandals or window
screens to stop insects from getting
into houses the hard plastic is the
organization's cash cow it brings in the
equivalent of 7,000 euros a year the
recycling center has acquired a new
shredder
soon it will be able to handle plastic
not just from all of what amo but from
another nearby community Jeffrey thinks
they'll be able to shred about twenty
thousand kilos of hard plastic more than
double their present capacity so I can
say this project has been so beneficial
on me and the project itself because up
to date the TACA TACA was too hot on the
beach are now reduced on the village
cyst and thanks to the initiative around
25 people in wat Tommo
are earning steady money shaquiesha was
unemployed for a long time until the
project hired him he lives for free on
the grounds of the recycling center he
mixes old paper water and wood chips to
make briquettes for burning
the business idea earns him the
equivalent of a hundred euros a month
from garbage community come I feel a
been getting up when the people from the
community collect those plastics and
bring them here they get money for the
plastic ono on effendi kaha believer
evil Jeffrey says the biggest challenge
is to make clear to the community that
recycling plastic is much more than just
a short-term money-making project the
challenge we do have is that because
people say ok I can join with you
working there but what I'm going to give
me you know so you have to pay him
instead of volunteering they don't
volunteer and they do have to volunteer
cause this this is their country the
environment belongs to them to the what
amo environmental activists want to do
more to educate the community Jeffrey
wants to make people understand that
recycling garbage is meaningful it looks
like he's already come a long way